c'est là que tout a commencé
la légende de candy man il se baladait
dans le quartier et distribuer des
friandises aux enfants
un jour des enfants ont trouvé des lames
de rasoir dans leurs bonbons
la police a débarqué
c'est là que j'ai vu le vrai visage de
la peur un genou dès maintenant ils
l'ont tabassé torturé et tué sans
sommation
quelques semaines plus tard d'autres
lame de rasoir ont apparu dans d'autres
bombes il était innocent donc il existe
candy man n'est pas un homme
candy man c'est toute la rue
si tu es venu chercher candy man
un bon conseil laisse tomber
je me sens en phase avec cette histoire
je t'écoute
c'est ici lui dans ce quartier
que la légende est née
et la légende raconte que si on dise en
ont cinq fois en regardant dans un
miroir on peut faire apparaître on
invoque candy man or des questions
candy man anthony non quand il arrête je
veux pas commencer à flipper dans le
nouvel appart avant de dormir quand les
noirs ont assez de problèmes comme ça
il faut oser great wall a des garçons
n'ont pas intérêt à dire le dernier
quand il m'a dit vous voulez faire
partie de l'histoire non
dit son
camp dit mano
[Musique]
un tony
anthony
inconnu
qu'est-ce qui se passe entamant ce
quartier hanté
je crois qu'il fait une erreur je les
ramène candide mal
je t'avais choisir
il avait un projet pour toi
bon
toi tu est nouveau aussi
il faut le dire quand des mâles dit
souvent
m